l'europe doit être un espace de libre
échange mais nous devons arrêter d'être
naïf et il faut que les échanges au
niveau européen et bien se fasse de
manière loyale vis-à-vis du reste du
monde mais aussi au sein de l'union
européenne
regardez les travailleurs détachés en
2010 7 500 mille travailleurs détachés
emmanuel macron se targue et bien
d'avoir lutté contre ce travail
détachées ce qu'il oublie de nous dire
c'est qu'il a complètement abandonné le
secteur du transport
regardez la politique industrielle en
france le problème
air france klm regarde et alstom et donc
c'est au niveau européen que nous devons
nous organiser nous devons nous battre
pour mettre en place comme le font les
autres pays en dehors de l'union
européenne et bien un made in europe les
etats unis le faut nous devons le faire
également